pictures from a local ukrainian channel
widely circulated on social media
the woman says hello to her family
we are all right we are okay she says
what happens next illustrates the sudden
severity of an artillery war
[Music]
ukrainians worry several donetsk will be
the next city to fall to russian
occupation
the russian advance is slow but it is
steady and russia now controls most of
the city
our plans are clear we will de-occupy
our entire territory which historically
belongs to us and in accordance with all
international laws this is our plan
we don't care about russia's plans we
are having difficulties in the east due
to the shortages of the right weapons
you know this well
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
was speaking during a visit by
slovakia's president
zuzana kapatova came bearing gifts more
howitzers destined for the front line
as street battles rage and several
donetsk russians are also striking other
cities in eastern ukraine
in nearby slovyansk residents cleared
debris from a russian missile strike on
tuesday
we have no place to go where would we go
we have no place to go
targeting civilian infrastructure is one
of the many allegations of russia's war
crimes discussed by ukraine's general
prosecutor with her international
criminal court counterparts at the hague
we have more than 600 suspects actually
it is high level of
top military militaries politicians and
propaganda agents of russian federation
when we speak about war crimes in
ukraine you know we have near 80
suspects people whom we identify as a
war criminals and started to prosecute
them
the court confirms it will be opening in
office in ukraine to investigate crimes
and collect evidence
on the same day in kiev a second war
crimes trial concluded
eleventh and a half year prison
sentences for two soldiers members of a
russian artillery unit guilty of
targeting civilian areas in kharkiv
in areas that were retaken ukrainians
are still digging up bodies in shallow
graves for autopsies and investigations
survivors and witnesses tell stories of
rape torture and murder ukrainians who
have survived occupation attacks on
their homes and are still at war with
russia
they say that speedy justice when it
comes to russian prisoners of war in
custody will be justice served zain
basravi al-jazeera kiev